president Donald Trump is so confident
in the drug he himself dubbed a
game-changer against kovat 19 that he
himself takes one pill of
hydroxychloroquine with zinc every
morning yeah I've taken it for about a
week and a half now and I'm still here
the president's unsolicited admission
came at the end of a winding press
conference next to restaurant executives
about reopening the country what do you
have to lose okay what do you have to
lose that's despite no evidence of the
drug working to prevent infection and
Trump's own Food and Drug Administration
warning against fusing
hydroxychloroquine to treat kovat
outside of an emergency hospital setting
a leading government immunologist
testified before congress last week that
he was demoted after doubting
hydroxychloroquine efficacy we also knew
that there were potential safety risk
for chloroquine to cause irregular
irregular heart rhythms and even in some
cases death a greater portion of US
military veterans who took the drug to
treat kovat 19 did die according to a
government study as compared to fellow
kovat patients who did not take
hydroxychloroquine and to larger studies
from New York found the drug offered no
significant benefit to hospitalized
patients Trump said his faith in
hydroxychloroquine comes from anecdotes
that make their way to the Oval Office
here's my evidence I get a lot of
positive calls about it
the American Medical Association says it
strongly opposes the non-fda-approved
use of hydroxychloroquine without
careful consultation with one's doctor
Trump says he has the White House
doctors approval he says he asked for it
himself
Heidi Joe Castro al Jazeera Washington